when the invasion started you were quite
praiseworthy of vladimir putin you said
he was a genius this was a savvy move
he was going in as a peacemaker no no
that's the fake news's version no tell
me the truth when he built up soldiers
on the border i said that's very smart
brilliant move
because i thought he was negotiating
when he went in i said no longer a
brilliant move when you see the scenes
mr president
of maternity hospitals i think it's
terrible when you see refugees being
attacked as they flee grandmothers
children babies
you see the decimation of
previously prosperous cities living in a
thriving new democracy when you watch
what's happening i mean do you agree
with my assessment that vladimir putin
is now an evil genocidal monster yeah
but i also do when i look at i do sure
who wouldn't what's happening is
horrible
when you see rockets going into
apartment buildings and there are plenty
of people in those buildings you know
they think they're like the people who
moved out they didn't move they want to
stay because they think they're safe in
their apartments far more people are
dead than you think when i see all the
death and all that destruction
and it's such a stupid war
because you had a country who was
working that was had problems lots of
problems but
other countries have problems too
it was such a horrible
waste to be doing it
you see swings outside you see
playgrounds you see hospitals it was a
country
and
the people were happy i guess a lot of
them were happy because they're
certainly fighting for it but i'll tell
you what i really think i said isn't it
a shame all those people are dead all
because of a rigged election because if
our election wasn't rigged you would
have had nobody dead when you said to
putin don't invade ukraine yeah what was
his well i told him what our response
was going to be and his response was
really i said really what did you say
your response and you know what if he
believed me good but if he believed me
only five percent he would have said
i'll never do it what did you say the
responsibility i'm not going to say that
i'm not going to say that but it was a
very strong response did you threaten
for example the nuclear capability i
don't want to talk about that
i don't want to talk about that what i
did say is
we're going to be
very strongly responding if you do
that i also said to president xi don't
go into taiwan
and there's going to be a very strong
response they both understood that they
both had the same reaction really
really
i said really
the thing that may keep him out of
taiwan is how poorly russia is doing
right and how vicious it has to be how
horrible it has to be because china sees
that and nobody wants to see what's
happening
so what would you do right now in
ukraine if you were the president putin
uses the n word i call it the n word he
uses the n word the nuclear word all the
time that's a no-no you're not supposed
to do that he uses it on a daily basis
and everybody's so afraid so afraid so
afraid and as they're afraid he uses it
more and more that's why he's doing the
kind of things he's doing
he's doing them because he thinks
nobody's gonna ever attack us because
they're all stupid and they're afraid to
talk i totally agree with you okay so
what would you do instead of excuse me
it's
a little complicated
instead of
you know cow towing instead of
biden saying oh
he's got nuclear weapons he keeps saying
he's got new
we have better
weapons that we have the greatest
submarine power
in history what would you say and do i
would say we have far more than you do
far
far more powerful than you and you can't
use that word ever again you cannot use
the nuclear word ever again and if you
do
we're going to have problems
my reading of what you've been saying is
that when you were talking to putin
when you were president and he was
talking about potentially invading
ukraine that you threatened him with
your nuclear capability i threatened him
like he has never been threatened before
did he threaten to use nuclear weapons i
don't want to say that i threatened him
like he has never been threatened before
what's your message for putin now right
now if you could talk to him what would
you say to him i i would say it's a
shame what you've done
you're killing protect i think
potentially look you know if these
people aren't smart
and they're not
our leaders are not smart
if they're not smart you're going to end
up in a nuclear war
this is just the beginning this is the
beginning and i've been the best
predictor of things ever now it doesn't
have to happen it shouldn't happen but
if our people aren't smart you can end
up in a nuclear war what's your message
i think they're dealing with he's
watching this interview and he will be
look what would you say i think they're
dealing with him incorrectly i think
what they're saying
it's almost like they're speaking with
fear and they don't understand we have
one weapon alone that would destroy
everything should putin get out of
ukraine right now they should make a
deal and they can make a deal and they
should do it fast when people look back
on this period of time
we're going to be ashamed at what we've
done
or what we haven't done to stop this
catastrophe this is a catastrophe this
is in a way already a world war has
russia made itself with this invasion
has it made itself an enemy of the
united states well i think two things
have happened number one they've proven
to be less powerful than we thought
that's a good thing from our standpoint
but at the same time they have a second
degree of weapon
that is very powerful
and
nobody can be allowed to use it talk
about it threaten with it
we have more powerful than them
and there would be no russia there would
be no russia but we don't want to talk
about that but when i watch biden say oh
he's got nuclear weapons we can't do
this
you can't do that you know i confronted
kim jong-un
and all of a sudden i got a call they'd
like to meet
it was like what do you think you're fun
to do
what did you say to him well verbally i
confronted him you know that
he said i have a red button on my desk
meaning a nuclear button i said
i have a red button on my desk too but
it's bigger and stronger than yours and
mine works
and they said well nobody's ever talked
to us that way i took a lot of a lot of
heat when i said that
would you look back on your term in
office and there may be another one
we'll come to that when you look back on
the the four years you were president of
the united states it was very polarizing
in many ways you know that what do you
think was your biggest success
so when you say polarizing i think it's
more polarized now than it ever i don't
disagree i don't disagree joe biden said
he would unify the country there's
certainly no sign of that happening so i
don't disagree with you well i think you
know that your own 10 years start with
your telling we'll come to joe biden but
your tenure four years give me the one
thing that you're proudest of i can't
say one because there are too many
things but i'll give you one that's a
lot of people don't talk about but then
they say wow that's true we started no
wars
we didn't have russia fighting in
ukraine we didn't have china threatening
every day
taiwan they wouldn't have done it and
russia would have never go into they
would have never gone into ukraine
never no chance how can you be sure
about i know it i know my people and i
know putin and he would have never done
it i think the the afghanistan
withdrawal was so incompetent
with the 85 billion and the dead
soldiers but to be clear you wanted
withdrawal you wanted us forces out of
afghanistan i'm the one that started it
right i took it down your complaint is
about the execution of the withdrawal
that's the actual decision to withdraw
withdrawal with strength and with
dignity but i was the one that got it
down to two thousand soldiers how would
you have done it if you'd still be
president number one very simple i would
have left the military to last not you
don't take out the military first we
took out our military first
a child would say you can't do that we
took the military out and then we had
thousands of people that were american
people some of whom are still there a
large number are still there bigger than
people think
uh i have never seen anything so
incompetent and in my opinion by the way
not only the soldiers that were killed
we have horribly horribly wounded
soldiers
and leaving 85
billion dollars of the best equipment in
the world best military club and leaving
millions of afghan women
in the hands of the taliban correct who
have immediately taken them back to the
dark age correctly by trashing their
education trashing their women's rights
i mean that's an abrogation of a moral
duty isn't it yeah it sure is
do you think that it fueled vladimir
putin's
ambitions with the ukraine invasion
seeing what appeared to be
america in surrender mode yes i think
that was the reason i think that's why
he did it when they saw the way we acted
in afghanistan the way we ran like
surrendered and again you have to
understand i had a
very strong very powerful relationship
powerful in the sense that they
respected our country and me
there was no games with the taliban and
its leader who's still their leader by
the way
and they would have never done this i'll
agree we ran away he said hey
this is no longer trump i'm going to go
in and take you but let me let me and
then it worked out to be not so good
you